welcome back to Las Vegas now it's that
time of year again Monday's dark returns
with its anniversary show celebrating
another successful year of giving back
to the community and here to tell us all
about it we have the Creator and our
friend of Monday's dark mark Chinook hi
Mark how's it going I love you thanks
for having me on prayers I can't believe
it was a whole year ago that you were
here talking about the last Monday's
dark and now you're doing it again tell
us about this here uh it just keeps
going it's that little show that just
keeps going not so little not so little
anymore uh we're creeping up on 165
local non-profits that we've supported
almost 2 million given back to the
community two million dollars raised and
December is always a year to just look
back on what we've done January through
November and celebrate all the
non-profits that we've supported and
partnered with and it's it's just a fun
fun night it's just goofy
congratulations on everything and you're
obviously doing something right because
that is incredible what you have done
for the community but I love this show
every year you bring in all different
entertainers it's a really big event
tell us who you have this year uh it's
an incredible lineup like you said Clint
Holmes is coming out Daniel Emmett
Lorena Peril uh but the big thing for us
is we announced the 21 non-profits that
we're going to feature in 2023 so it's
the 21 charity partners that we had this
year the 21 for next year so 42 local
non-profits Under One Roof wow we're
about 200 tickets away from selling out
the Pearl we're set up for 1900 people
so this will probably be our biggest
attended Monday's dark that we've ever
done but that's just a testament to
Vegas and the people who call it home I
always get asked why do you do this it's
because of the people who live and
breathe and make Vegas go the parties
are cool the buildings are cool the
restaurants that we have access to here
are great but what makes Vegas so
special are the people who live here and
that's why Monday's Dart continues to
keep doing what it does well it's so
cool and it's so special to have that
Community here and all the support which
I'm sure just makes you happy every time
you stand up on that stage you can see
everyone out there and last year you had
a special guest and I had Twain show up
which I know you're friends with her
anything you can do can't tell you no I
can't tell you you have to be in the
room we have 130 silent auction items
wow that just went live today so we have
a shopping spree happening so if you're
watching follow us on social media and
just help us out even if you don't come
to the event there's so many ways to
support these amazing non-profits
absolutely well do come to the event
because I promise you it's a lot of fun
it's happening next Monday at the Provo
there's just a few tickets left
go to your website mondaysdark.com doors
at seven show at eight we're gonna pack
the Pearl at the Palms it's going to be
a night not to miss well thank you Mark
you're like the busiest man in Las Vegas
and you still make time to do all this
so we appreciate you for having all of
the information on your screen Monday's
our ninth anniversary celebration
happening December 12th that's over at
the Palms for tickets again go to
mondaystark.com thank you so much for
being here Rocky let's send it over to
you and see what she's up to with Santa